I sent a tweet it was last November I
think about you know the film Mary
Poppins it's a motor problem Julie
Andrews I've seen it was resina right so
she ends up with a covered with chimney
soot on her eyes and so titania tweeted
saying this was blackface the picture of
Julie Andrews with Jim you said this is
black place it's disgusting and then
five months later the New York Times ran
an article saying exactly that right now
I predicted it and it's almost like I'm
not saying I've got magical powers or
anything but it is that thing of you
know what how can you win the when real
life is catching up with you so much
there's virtually nothing that I could
tweet that eventually won't happen this
is the Reuben report and according to
the Senate inquiry I'm Dave Rubin quick
reminder guys that the Reuben report app
is here just search Reuben report in the
App Store or on Google Play and join our
troll free community where you can get
ad free video and audio podcasts connect
with other viewers and even little ol me
for more info go to Reuben report come
out more importantly than that joining
me today is a comedian author and
dissector of social justice
Andrew Doyle welcome to the Reuben
report nice to see ya
how's it going it is going well I feel
this is overdue for many reasons okay
cuz you know as a guy that came from the
left and started saying these people are
no longer liberal yeah what's this
social justice thing and
intersectionality and all of it yeah you
are sort of the the king or the queen
don't misgender me but it's one or the
other yeah sure I think I love this you
were gonna clear the queen of this thing
I mean I've had that similar that I mean
I'm accused of often going over to the
right which isn't really the case you
know I don't see you know I come from a
leftist background but I I think that
conservatives are right about some
things I think left-wing people are
right about other things and you know I
think if you subscribe to an ideology
wholesale and you just say that's me I'm
gonna agree with those points then
you're not really thinking for yourself
and that scares me a little bit so I
don't do that yeah all right well we're
gonna have to clean up some of that in
the course of this next hour now and the
little confused though because when when
we were pitched you yes this is your
book well it's the Townies book well so
this is the the confusion so I thought
that we were having to Tanya McGrath on
the show yeah she's not available
and it's called woke and it's a guide to
social justice yeah and I thought we
were having miss McGrath yeah yeah here
we end up with you so I'm a little
confused can you possibly dissect this
for me well she's out and about she's
doing her protesting I guess she's
probably gluing herself to someone's
front door who's considered a and
negative influence on society you know
that's her kind of thing but actually
the truth is she doesn't exist you know
so she I created her flow in my mind I
know it's not it's not a revelation
really yeah she it was April 2018 and I
thought I'm gonna create a fake
character to satirize the social justice
movement well the excesses of the social
justice movement you know and so I
wanted to do this sort of slam poet very
pretentious young very narcissistic kind
of very privileged person who wants to
nevertheless say that she's oppressed so
reveling in oppression and victimhood
and all of that stuff you know this is
quite a recognizable type of person yes
seeing one or two people on the Twitter
and they're kind of funny you know
because there's a lot of them
particularly UK there's a lot of these
sort of left-leaning people they write
tend to write for things like The
Guardian and the independent and they're
very all about their victim status but
they come from sort of independently
millionaire backgrounds and they don't
see that that's funny I find that
hilarious and of course they are fully
and the other thing about them of course
if they don't they don't want to sit and
debate and reason and talk and so
therefore the best thing to do I think
is mop them and poke fun of them and the
hope was but if I presented their own
sort of failings to them through this
caricature who obviously says things
that are beyond what most normal people
say it is as sort of character is an
extreme but I thought it might maybe
start some kind of process of
self-reflection potentially it doesn't
it just seems to have got them angry
well it's funny because when I see -
Tanya's Twitter account when I first saw
it so this is now a year and a half ago
or so it's hard to tell what satire no
more because the things that you or she
is tweeting about they sound very much
like the stuff that were constantly
thrown at by mainstream media actually
even though you're trying to be
over-the-top and oh yeah and quite
absurd when it catches up I mean so I'm
telling my face like so I give an
example they say I sent a tweet
it was last November I think about you
know the film Mary Poppins it's a motor
problem Judy Andrea I've seen it was
heard or seen aright so she ends up with
a covered with chimney soot on her eyes
and so titania tweeted saying this was
blackface the picture of Julie Andrews
with Jim you said this is black place
it's disgusting and then five months
later the New York Times ran an article
saying exactly that right now I'd
predicted it and it's almost like I'm
not saying I've got magical powers or
anything but it is that thing of you
know what how can you wonder when real
life is catching up with you so much
there's virtually nothing that I could
tweet that eventually won't happen and
then when I did a joke tweet about the
Queen it was the Queen's Speech at
Christmas and I was saying that she
should the listing the things she should
have said and I was saying that she
should have said what about the new
Royal baby and how it should be raised
as gender-fluid yeah and then lo and
behold that was raised by Megan a few
months later it's like well I you know I
on one side it's funny and then it also
depresses me a little bit that these
things happen okay so before we get too
far into the psychology yeah can you
just explain a little bit of your back
and as you said you grew up kind of kind
of lefty comedy all of that stuff just
react for the people that don't know
okay yeah so um I've been a writer for a
long time but I started out in academia
and I wanted to get out of that pretty
quickly you teach I was teaching
Shakespeare I was teaching the
Shakespeare mantra Oxford University was
there a connection between the social
justice thing and wanting to get out a
teacher well I'm I was in Wotton College
at Oxford which is the most sort of it's
known for being the most woke College
Oxford College before the word work was
even being used by most people it wasn't
connected no it was it was you know I I
I just thought thought I'm stuck in
libraries all the time it's quite
depressing and I thought I'd better get
out of that so I went out I started
writing this sort of comedy plays and
doing stand-up in London and then I I
ran out of money and I had nothing so I
was teaching so I took up sort of
secondary school teaching I did that for
about seven years and all the while I
was doing stand-up and all the while I
was writing plays and writing stuff like
that so that's my sort of background and
I've been on the comedy circuit for a
long time in about 15 years now
so how woke is Oxford generally because
I've seen I was there a couple times
when I was on tour with Jordan and I
spoke at Oxford Union and I thought the
questions were we're really rich and
interesting but then you could feel that
there is this strain of something
getting into the
this greatest place of higher learning
like this scary thing well this there's
evidence to suggest that the most
privileged student the most privileged
people the richest in other words are
far more likely to be social justice
activists right and spikes online does a
survey of universities every year and
every single year it's determined that
the ones that are the worst offenders
when it comes to censorship when it
comes to free speech tend to be from the
kids who were the poshest who have the
most stuff right so it's not really
surprising that you get them the woke
elements at Oxford but as a kind of
caveat to that what I would say is I you
know I do talks at universities around
the country and what I've noticed is the
kids are often great and they're often
not these sort of snowflakes that people
make them out to be they're not they
want to be challenged and the number the
people that I've spoken to they want to
be challenged they want to they want to
hear the other side even if they don't
necessarily agree it's generally the
academics right I did a talk at an at
university recently where the students
were great they wanted to be challenged
but then the the the politics Department
refused to publicize my appear or her
because they said any talk that was
antithetical to what culture was against
their diversity policy so they they
refute boycotted it completely so I
often find it's my generation that are
the worst when it comes to this stuff
how old are you I'm fine if you don't
mind me not at all you're a gen Xer like
mine I I'm a gen Xer yeah yeah yeah you
know it's so interesting because I agree
with that even though we see the
snowflakes of colleges and the screaming
people and the means of all that stuff
but it does seem to really come from the
academic layer I was giving a talk about
six months ago at a school and a guy
came up to me after he was older than an
average college student and he told me
that he was a veteran and he started
college late he said that he was in a
philosophy class earlier in the day and
the philosophy professor instructed them
not to go to Dave Reubens all right talk
Wow that evening and he said he said I'm
a little older than these students so I
didn't want to embarrass the teacher in
front of class so I went up to him after
and I said can you tell me what all
right opinions they had been hold and
the professor basic said well I don't
know but I've read that yeah sure and he
was like I tried to ask get the
professor to come here but then of
course he wouldn't come and the rest of
it but yeah the idea that they're just
being hit with this stuff I mean there's
when they when they're the most
impression exactly but some on some of
the university I think
it takes a certain degree of education
to say things like that because because
it's stupidity it's a kind of learning
stupidity which is really it's really
odd isn't it
and I think it's because when I was at
university there was all this kind of
post-structuralism
there was all this kind of focus on
dairy down Foucault and all that kind of
thing and it was sort of dying off a few
years ago and now that's gone mainstream
and I don't know why I find that really
weird do you have suspicions as to why
it's good being through many theories I
don't know why and I'm often asking this
question I do want to know what it is I
I I can't fathom it actually I don't
know why it involves a kind of
substitution of slogans for a lack of
thought you know so you get these
phrases like lived-experience better why
right here yeah so what this means is
you know when you discuss this stuff
with whether social justice activists i
guarante when i talk to a social justice
activist i know what their opinion is
about absolutely everything as soon as
i've said one thing they're just
repeating a script and that to me is
really that's not freedom of thought
right that's that's that's an
ideological adherence and they use these
phrases and then when you challenge them
on the phrases they don't know what to
do with that to then lived experiences
just well that's that ends the
discussion right well actually lived
experience we used to call that
anecdotal evidence and we used to
dismiss it right you know but now we
actually it has some kind of weird
weight if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell